[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very very much we are so lucky
these people cheered you putting on a
hat I know no I was gonna say that guy I
don't know that guy I swear on my life I
don't know that guy but I know he wore
that hat and sat up close because he
knows I can't resist a depression-era
cap like just he's reeling you in right
now
no he knew he was taunting me and he was
wiggling it around you're gonna come for
and I always dooms I gotta put it on it
oh hi yep I just have to do it thank you
so much for being here we have a
fantastic show yeah our show is now half
as long but four times the laughs yeah
that's not possible with they were
basically saying here's the old show had
no laughs yeah you know I get tired it's
a long stretch let's take that camera
angle again I always loved there you go
can I have the Hat I think it's gonna
look a lot better with the hat in the
foreground and Andy is the rich uncle
that adopted me and I'm I'm the poor
away from the foreground here we go
who are you I don't know who this man is
but he's not responsible for half of our
show and now everybody knows they can
entrap you with a hat you can entrap me
with a hat you know one of the things
we're trying a bunch of new things one
of the things I'm very passionate about
is I want this show to be positive I
really do I want it to be positive there
was so much negativity out there tunne
isn't it just a ton of negativity right
now and I want to inject our show with
positivity but it's tough because every
day you look at the news we all know
that news stories I'm talking about but
there's occasionally these news stories
that are it's completely gratuitous
completely gratuitous there's this news
story about the Doomsday Clock
today you know that clock it's a
fictional clock that supposedly tells us
when the world is gonna end someone made
that up like we need that right now
well guess what the idiots who have the
Doomsday Clock they moved the clock to
two minutes till midnight this is a news
story it is now at two minutes from doom
two minutes from doom so I had well
first of all I want to thank this
audience for spending the last minutes
of your life with me
the second thing is to me it's so
subjective
who's the guy running the Doomsday Clock
what if he just had a bad night went out
right had a date didn't go well she
wasn't interested
he went home drank a lot was looking at
that clock sure it was like we're all
gonna go together
I just hate Diane yeah Diane yeah that's
your name yeah all right
it's Diane apparently